No, I'm not about to play a pickup game of basketball, I'm gonna cook!
"Oh no."
Hi my name's Grace Helbig if you did not know, now you know, your life is different now!
Alright
I don't know if this video is gonna see the light of day, but I figured I might ummm
Shoot something that I was going to do anyway,
and that is bake.
Tomorrow I'm headed out of town for five days, which means I'm leaving Elliott behind in Los Angeles for five days.
So I thought I would do something nice for him before I leave - something to remember me by. Five days is a long time.
In the state of the world that we're currently living in who the **** knows what's gonna happen in those five days? I'm gonna make a very
specifically wonderful treat. Also he's home. He's in the room over there and I've asked him not to listen
I wanna surprise him with this situation. He knows something's happening, but. I have a feeling he's ****ing listening and because he can't help himself...
So if I whisper sometimes that's why. ASMR. Lucky you. And by the looks of everything I have gathered here
you might think I'm gonna make a regular
awesome, funfetti cake. Yes, I am, in a way
but I'm making it
unique for a very special human being, but I don't want to tell you exactly what the outcome is gonna be
I want you to watch along and see if you can figure it out as we go!
Let's start making some funfetti cake!
Also
I got rid of so much sh*t in my kitchen in an effort to clean out my whole house that I hardly have
things to cook with. I just bought these off of Amazon a half hour ago.
This is the only bowl I have left in my house currently and it's a salad bowl, but it has this area in it open
so we will be mixing everything in here. We're just gonna follow the directions on the box.
The decorating is where the unique loving expression is really gonna come in to play.
I ****ing love funfetti, because I have trash taste. Trash taste is very trendy right now.
That's me to myself by myself every day. This goes in. God, I already love it so much.
It looks like you know, rave cocaine. Okay. Oh, I threw the box away that has the...goddammit... Preheat our oven to 350 degrees, haha.
One cup of water one half cup of oil. I'm going to use these! Wanna hear a really gross story?
There was a point in my life where I would buy funfetti cake batter and I'd put water in it and mix it up,
and then just eat it with a spoon.
That was not a great time in my life.
Oil!
And then 3 eggs. One, two, three! Now we mix it! If you've a mixer mix it, if you don't have a mixer...we really do need gun control.
I have a whisk. This looks so good.
Now, we're going to load up our pans to cook it and normally if you're making regular funfetti
You can make cupcakes you can make just round
regular cakes. I'm making a more abstract
scenario here. So I have this meat loaf pan
I don't know the appropriate name. Fill up a little bit of the way and then I'm gonna make some cupcakes.
This is a very terrible bowl to pour in. Even though I got rid of 12,000 items in my kitchen
I somehow kept a melon baller.
Woooow. Our oven's ready!
These are gonna go in the oven now for...oh.
15 to 20 minutes and check in on them. I'll put a toothpick in and see if it slides out clean.
Heheehh, it's so many sexual innuendos. Good luck my treasures!
In the meantime, we're going to make sure it's not poisoned. Wow eating off of a whisk is the grossest thing.
Ohhh, I'm excellent at doing things. I know it's got raw egg in it.
You have raw egg in it. If you're a lady, you know I'm talking about.
beepbeepbeepbeepbeep, gross.
*beeping* Let's test it. Okay.
Oooo! They look like they've been cooking! Basically, what I hear is you put one of these toothpicks in you pull it out
if it's got sh*t on it it's not done, if it doesn't have sh*t on it *clicks*
Okay! Cupcakes are done, meatloaf cake needs some more time, we'll be right back. Oh, sorry
I forgot to update you that the meatloaf cake is done, everything is out of the oven
we are going to let it cool down and
*whispers* then we're gonna ****ing decorate it.
Cakes are done,
I put them in the freezer to cool down really quickly because I'm an impatient little bitch. And now we're gonna decorate and this is
where it all comes together. So I'm just gonna show you this in a beautiful artistic montage.
*mischievous music plays*
Ta-da!
We did it. You get it?
*whispers* It's blue baaallls.
I'm a genius
*whispers* Now let's see what he thinks.
Oh, I want to cover it
That's great.
Hey Elliott, you wanna come see your surprise?
Do you want to come see your surprise because I'm leaving?
Are you...
Okay, okay. You can take this off. Be careful.
G: You can be louder. E: Is it a dick and, it's a penis and test it's uhh... baby thank you, I'm so excited
G: Do you understand what it is?
E: Um, it's a penis and it's because you're, I'm, yeah.
G: What color are the balls?
E: Yeah, so I... *laughter*
E: It's very funny. G: But for people that are colour-blind out there, can you tell them what color the balls are?
E: The balls are blue balls. Thank you baby.
G: You're welcome! This took way too long to do! Do you like it? E: Um. I love it.
G: Thank you guys for watching!
I don't know if I'll even post this video but subscribe if you've made it this far, and go check out
Elliott over at the Valleyfolk! E: You'll post it, you'll post it. G: ...sure! Other than that, I don't know.
E: Can I have some? G: Yeah, go for it! You can taste it! I mean I'm curious to see which part you uh, attempt to eat first.
E: Symbolically, I'm gonna try to take care of the blue balls first. G: Yeah yeah yeah, you gotta empty those.
G: Did I do it right? Yeeeeah, you look like you have hypothermia now, haha!